hey guys it's Jonah here so I'm someone
who need to have my breakfast to start
my day right thumb up if you are the
same having breakfast isn't just about
maintaining a healthy weight but it is
so important to give you the energy for
your body and brain to work at their
best if I don't have my breakfast I
can't seem to focus or be productive a
lot of people I've met always tell me
they don't have time to prep or even eat
breakfast in the morning it's just too
much of a hassle I get that if I'm on a
tight schedule I prefer to have my
breakfast on the go so recently I've
been introduced to chair pudding and I
must say I'm hooked this nutrient packed
breakfast in a jar can be put together
in under five minutes with less than
five ingredients it is so simple you can
even get your kids to help out so make
them a head keep them in the fridge and
in the morning just grab one jar and
you're set for a productive day ahead
chia seed is extremely nutrient dense
and packs a lot of energy boosting power
it is very high in fiber which promotes
healthy digestion because of all the
fiber chia seeds can absorb up to ten
times their weight in water becoming
some sort of putting like and expand in
the stomach when eaten which keeps you
full very quickly it is also a great
source of calcium for those of you who
don't eat dairy so this tiny jar will
keep you satisfied until lunch time to
make the tropical mango chirping you'll
need quarter cup of chai seeds 1 cup of
any milk of your choice one teaspoon of
maple syrup or honey one cup of mango
puree and one tablespoon of pumpkin
seeds pour the mango puree
evenly into two 8-ounce jars and chill
in the fridge in a bowl mix together the
charrids milk and honey stir until well
combined
then pour the charr mixture on top of
the mango puree cover and let it set
overnight in the fridge and in the
morning top it up with a little bit of
pumpkin seeds sill and bring it out with
you this has to be one of my favorite
combinations because you're getting the
natural sweetness from the mango
combined with the thick creamy chap
pudding topped with crunchy seeds right
my next combination has to include much'
powder it is known for its high
antioxidants coming properties and also
to boost metabolism plus I just love
green tea so what you'll need are cut a
cup of chai seeds 1 cup of any milk of
your choice 1 teaspoon of maple syrup or
honey 1 teaspoon of matcha green tea and
1 cup of mixed berries in a bowl mix
together the chia seeds milk honey and
matcha powder stir until well combined
divide equally into two jars cover and
let it set overnight in the fridge
the next morning just top it up with
mixed berries and enjoy this is a really
good way to add green tea into your diet
and to gain the health benefits each jar
is under 300 calories but it will still
feel your up in the morning it is a
great choice for those of you who are
watching your weight so I hope that you
would give this much a check putting a
try it is not weird in fact it is very
yummy I promise and another of my
favorite combination has to be the
classic mix of banana and peanut butter
what you'll need are quarter cup of chia
seeds 1 cup of any milk of your choice
1 teaspoon of maple syrup or honey 1
large banana mashed and 2 tablespoons of
peanut butter in a bowl mix together the
mashed banana chia seeds milk honey and
peanut butter stir until well combined
then divide equally into two jars cover
and let it set overnight in the fridge
having this is like
having dessert for breakfast it is so
yummy rich and filling - the guilt I can
seriously indulge in this every day and
I trust that your kids will love it
so char pudding is a quick very easy to
make
convenient grab and go breakfast when
you're flying out the door this tiny jar
is packed with antioxidants protein
calcium fiber and healthy fat so it's
perfect not just for breakfast but as a
healthy snack and they will sit well in
the fridge for up to four days so you
should not have any excuse to skip
breakfast be sure to make them try them
and share your pictures with me on
Instagram and Facebook all the best
you